ils trônent dans l'allée des pommiers à
coignières pourtant il s'agit d'un
poirier mais pas n'importe lequel
nous sommes devant l'arbre remarquable
de coignières fin recensés comme tels
dénommé poirier de la saint-martin et on
voit sur le panneau qui a été posé qui
essaie tant il a été à rebours de
l'année 2016 donc sélectionné parmi les
20 plus beaux arbres d'île de france
pour l'année 2016
cet arbre remarquable a été planté ici
il y à plus de 120 ans sa spécificité
c'est que eh bien il est très ancien
bien sûr ce sont des variétés qui sont
plutôt en voie de disparition
il est en très bon état sanitaire il
fait environ on avait évalué à 17 18
mètres de hauteur à peu près une
circonférence qui fait de m 80 quand
même et puis l'aspect on le voit bien 2
les corses aussi quand ça part en vrille
comme ça c'est caractéristique des
arbres anciens
[Musique]
considéré comme porte étendard des
poiriers de la ville la mairie souhaite
l'intégrer dans son projet d'autonomie
alimentaire et d'alimentation locale
déjà c'est un arbre au courant
ancien de variétés relativement peu
répandu donc on peut s'en servir pour
prélever des greffons pour le multiplier
en gros il peut être intéressant parce
qu'il peut donner des enfants des
enfants qui pourraient être plantés dans
cette allée dans quelques mois
l'idée de la mairie serait d'organiser à
l'avenir une fête autour de la récolte
des poires en attendant notre arbre
remarquable devrait se refaire une
beauté en automne avec une taille douce
un toilettage nécessaire tous les dix
ans
[Musique]